Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast der ESA und des DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 13. Ausgabe in dieser Serie, in der sich viel schon im Orbit abgespielt hat, wir aber auch häufig den Blick zurück auf die Erde gewagt haben. Und dazwischen befand sich immer etwas, was am Rande auch zur Sprache kam, aber was so noch nicht die notwendige Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat, was aber in dem ganzen Zusammenspiel und vor allem in den wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen, die in der Raumfahrt auch einen großen Stellenwert einnehmen, eine große Rolle spielt und zwar die Atmosphäre unseres Planeten der Erde. Und darum soll es heute gehen und ich begrüße dazu als Gesprächspartnerin für die heutige Ausgabe Bernadette Weinzierl. Hallo, wir befinden uns in Oberpfaffenhofen, ein weiteres Mal am DLR, nicht dem einzigen, aber einem großen Standort des DLR. Dein Institut ist das Institut für Physik der Atmosphäre. Hab ich das richtig zusammengekratzt? Das heißt, das Institut setzt sich mit der Atmosphäre im Allgemeinen und im Besonderen auseinander. Was steht da so im Fokus? Womit setzt sich dieses Institut auseinander?
Also wir haben mehrere Abteilungen, insgesamt fünf. Eine Abteilung beschäftigt sich mit der Dynamik der Atmosphäre, also wie ziehen Hoch- und Tiefdruckgebiete, aber auch wie wird sich das Klima in Zukunft entwickeln? Die machen auch Modellrechnungen zum Klima. Dann gibt es eine Abteilung, die macht Flugzeugmessungen. Das ist die Abteilung, in der auch ich bin. Wir messen, wie viele Aerosolpartikel zum Beispiel in der Atmosphäre sind oder welche Spurngase zum Beispiel in Vulkanen ausstoßen. Dann gibt es eine Abteilung, die beschäftigt sich mit der Ferienerkundung. Die nutzt Satellitendaten, um besser zu verstehen, wie Wolken das Klima beeinflussen. Es gibt eine weitere Abteilung, die sich mit Verkehrsmitrologie und Wolkenphysik beschäftigt. Die liefern dann wirklich auch Daten ins Cockpit, zum Beispiel über Gewitter, wo befindet sich eine Gewitterwolke, wohin wird sie ziehen, damit der Pilot den möglichst kurzen Flugweg drum herumfliegen kann. Dann gibt es noch eine fünfte Abteilung, die befasst sich mit LIDAR-Messungen. LIDAR ist eine Methode, in der man einen Laserpuls in die Atmosphäre aussendet und aufgrund der Laufzeit dann sagen kann, in welcher Höhe sich zum Beispiel eine Aerosol-Schicht befindet. In dieser Abteilung wird sehr viel Technologie entwickelt, zum einen für Flugzeugmessungen, zum anderen auch für zukünftige Satelliten-Missionen.
Das heißt, die ganze Arbeit des Instituts steht sowohl so unter dem Gesichtspunkt Wetter, Wetterlage, Wetterforschung, aber auch Umweltuntersuchung im weiteren Sinne.
Genau.
Bis hin zu Klimamodellen und der Auseinandersetzung mit der ganzen Frage, wohin geht es mit unserem Klima. Genau. Was ist da jetzt dein eigener Weg dorthin gewesen? Also wie kommt man da hin?
Also ich hab Meteorologie studiert und klar, da beschäftigt man sich schon mit Wolken und mit den Strömungen in der Atmosphäre und ich muss zugeben, mich hat einfach immer schon das Fliegen auch fasziniert. Und wir haben im Studium ein Praktikum, wo man Messflüge mit so kleinen Kleinflugzeugen macht. Da kann man bis drei Kilometer Höhe aufsteigen und wir hatten dann Thermometer dabei und haben die Temperaturen, die Feuchtigkeit gemessen und das hat mich sehr fasziniert und der Pilot von dem Flugzeug...
Die Uni hat selber ein Flugzeug?
Nee, die Uni arbeitet da mit dem DLR zusammen und der Pilot war eben vom DLR und hat dann erzählt, was die da machen und ich fand das immer schon sehr spannend.
Welcher Uni, welcher Studiengang war das genau?
Das war an der LMU und damals war das noch der Diplom-Studiengang Meteorologie. Jetzt ist das umgewandelt in den Bachelor-Studiengang Physik plus Meteorologie und man kann dann hinterher noch einen Master machen in Meteorologie.
Und da war dann sozusagen schon die Begeisterung?
Genau, da war die Begeisterung fürs Fliegen da und irgendwie hatten wir dann auch schon im Hinterkopf gehabt, DLR sind ziemlich, die machen ziemlich tolle Sachen. Und dann hat sich so ergeben, dass als ich mit dem Studium fertig war, war da eine Doktoranden-Stelle ausgeschrieben am DLR. Ging es eben um Flugzeugmessungen und dachte ich mir, ja das ist meine Stelle und ich hab sie dann auch Gott sei Dank bekommen.
Was war das für ein Flugzeug?
Das ist das Forschungsflugzeug Falcon. Das ist ein Jet, der kann bis zu 12 Kilometer Höhe fliegen und kann die ganze Troposphäre proben.
Das Flugzeug hat ja auch eine große Rolle gespielt vor gut einem Jahr bei der Auswertung der Folgen des Vulkans mit den unaufsprechlichen Namen. Da kommen wir gleich noch zu. Aber was mich noch interessieren würde, du hast dich quasi dann einfach beim DLR beworben und bist mehr oder weniger direkt vom Studium dann dorthin.
Genau.
Okay, also keine großen Umwege genommen.
Also ich habe am Ende vom Studium auch noch mein Praktikum am DLR gemacht, damals in der Abteilung für Wolkenphysik und Verkehrsmetrologie und es hat mich darin bestärkt, dass ich dahin will.
In die Wolken.
Wo die Freiheit grenzenlos ist.
Meistens, wenn keine Aschewolke da ist.
Wenn keine Aschewolke da ist. Ja, die Atmosphäre. Wir haben den Titel auch bewusst ein bisschen allgemeiner gehalten, weil ich denke, immer wieder klar geworden ist, auch bei verschiedenen Gesprächen, die wir hier schon geführt haben, dass so ein gewisses Grundverständnis der Atmosphäre nicht schadet. Zumal es eben häufig auch einen Einfluss hat. Das kam zum Beispiel in der Folge zum Thema Erdbeobachtung, Feinerkundung ganz deutlich raus. Einfach das Fotografieren von oben, das betrachten wollen bestimmte Eigenschaften. Aus Höhen wird eben erschwert durch die Atmosphäre bzw. muss eben aus einer bestimmten Höhe gewacht werden. So kommen mal Flugzeuge, mal eher Satelliten zum Einsatz. Je nachdem, mit unterschiedlichen Methoden, mit Infrarot, mit Radar etc. Aber auch in der Folge, wo es um Satellitennavigation ging und Ablenkung von Funksignalen etc. Verzögerungen, die auftreten, weil Signale eben erst mal durch die atmosphärischen Schichten gehen mussten. Das sind alles so Punkte, wo man sich eben dann doch schnell fragt, wie hängt denn das zusammen? Was muss man denn so wissen? Also, woraus setzt sich diese Atmosphäre zusammen und was ist so die Maßgabe, die dazu führt, dass man so verschiedene Schichten unterscheidet?
Also, die Atmosphäre ist ja die Gashülle, die unseren Planeten umgibt. Sie ist ungefähr 600 Kilometer dick und je nachdem, von welchem Feld ich komme, unterteilt man die in verschiedene Schichten. Wenn ich jetzt mehr aus dieser Satelliten-Navigations-Ecke komme, würde ich die Atmosphäre in eine Ionosphäre, das ist der obere Teil, wo man eben nicht mehr neutral geladene Atome hat, einteilen und in eine Neutrosphäre und wir, die wir uns mit dem Wetter befassen, teilen die Atmosphäre aufgrund der Temperaturschichtung in verschiedene Schichten ein.
600 Kilometer, gemeinhin sagt man ja, Weltraum ist ab 100. Das heißt, tatsächlich befindet sich auch so das meiste der Weltraumaktivitäten, Raumstationen hatten wir ja auch schon, die fliegen bei 350 Kilometer, viele Low-Orbit-Projekte befinden sich im Bereich, eigentlich befindet sich alles immer noch so im Dunstkreis der Erde im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Dunstkreis ist vielleicht auch der richtige Begriff, weil die Luft, die wird immer weniger dicht, die weite ich weggehe von der Atmosphäre und die meiste Masse von der Atmosphäre befindet sich unterhalb von 10, 12 Kilometern. Und unterhalb von 5,5 Kilometer hat man sogar die Hälfte der Masse der Atmosphäre, also das heißt, das meiste ist relativ nah am Erdboden.
Das heißt, obwohl man jetzt bis 600 Kilometer zählt, zählt das da oben schon nicht mehr so in dem Maße. So, jetzt hast du gesagt, es gibt verschiedene Schichten, Ionosphäre. Was war die Unterscheidung, Ionosphäre und Neutrosphäre?
Neutrosphäre, einfach im unteren Bereich der Atmosphäre sind die meisten Atome neutral geladen, deswegen Neutrosphäre. Und wenn ich darüber bin, dann bin ich in einem Bereich, wo ich eben Ionen hab, geladene Atome.
Und warum ist das so? Weil einfach die Luftschichten dort noch so direkt nackt dem Weltall ausgesetzt werden und durch die Strahlung entsprechend bearbeitet werden. Und das bedingt dann eben auch das einflussnehmende Verhalten auf Funkkommunikation mit Satelliten.
Genau, aber das ist mit der Funkkommunikation nicht mein Themengewicht.
Aber das heißt, unten ist am meisten los. Die unterste Sphäre ist die Troposphäre.
In der nimmt die Temperatur mit der Höhe ab. Das haben wir alle schon erfahren. Wenn ich auf einen Berg raufgehe, auf einen 3 km hohen Berg, dann ist da oben meistens kälter und die Luft ist auch weniger dicht. Das merkt man dadurch, dass manche Leute Probleme mit der Atmung kriegen. Oder dass man das einfach spürt, dass man auf großer Höhe ist und nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Und wie hoch ist diese Sphäre genau?
Die ist so 8 bis 16 km hoch, je nachdem, ob ich mich jetzt eher am Äquator befinde oder am Pol. Am Äquator ist sie höher als in den Polgebieten. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass ich am... Wir auf der Erde kriegen ja unsere Energie von der Sonne. Und die Erde ist eine Kugel und am Äquator kommt auf eine Fläche, wenn ich mir mal so einen Quadratzentimeter vorstelle, dann kriege ich einfach mehr Energie an. Und deswegen kann ich die Troposphäre bis zu einer größeren Höhe durchmischen. Und diese durchmischte Schicht, in der sich auch das Wetter abspielt, das sind dann diese...
Das heißt, weil mehr Sonnenstrahlung quasi direkt auftrifft, entwickelt sich dort mehr Wärme. Also wenn wir von Energie an der Stelle reden, reden wir von Wärmeentwicklung.
Genau. Und was ja dann passiert, wenn sich der Erdboden erwärmt, dann kriege ich ja irgendwann diese Thermikbewegungen, die jeder Siegelflieger kennt. Das sind aufsteigende Luftbewegungen. Und dadurch durchmische ich die untere Troposphäre. Also ich kriege aufsteigende Luftbewegungen. Die Luft kühlt sich ab. In der Luft habe ich ja auch den Wasserdampf. Ab einer bestimmten Temperatur ist ja nicht mehr als Dampf vorhanden, sondern es fangen sich an, Tröpfchen zu bilden. Und dann kriege ich Wolken und dann kann es regnen. Das kennen wir alle.
Das heißt, das macht sozusagen aus, dass die Troposphäre unterschiedliche Dichten hat. Und das gilt dann auch für die nachfolgenden Schichten?
Also die Höhe der Troposphäre, die wir haben geredet.
Und gilt das dann auch für die nachfolgenden Schichten? Also ist am Pol alles ein bisschen flacher und der luftfreie Weltraum fängt da früher an? Oder ist das jetzt eigentlich...
Am meisten ist das schon in der Troposphäre. Das ist auch so der Bereich, wo sich unser Wetter quasi abspielt, der für uns am interessantesten ist.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich der relevante Bereich für die Meteorologie, kann man sagen.
Ja, also relevant ist nicht nur die Troposphäre, sondern auch noch die Stratosphäre. In der Stratosphäre nimmt die Temperatur mit der Höhe wieder zu. Das liegt daran, dass wir in der Stratosphäre zwischen 20 und 30 Kilometer Höhe sehr viele Ozone-Moleküle haben. Die sind sehr wichtig für unser Leben, weil sie das UV-Licht absorbieren und dadurch von uns schädliche UV-Strahlung abhalten. Die Stratosphäre ist auch sehr wichtig für das Wetter.
Die Stratosphäre folgt...
Beziehungsweise für die ganzen Strömungen.
Die Stratosphäre folgt auf die Troposphäre?
Ja, dazwischen ist noch die Tropopause, die haben wir vergessen. In der ist die Temperatur mit der Höhe konstant und dann steigt die Temperatur mit der Höhe.
Das heißt, unten ist es am heißesten. Wenn man dann weiter nach oben geht, wird es immer kälter. Ich weiß nicht, wie kalt ist es am Ende der Troposphäre?
Ja, so minus 50, minus 60 Grad. Wenn man im Flugzeug sitzt und 10, 12 Kilometer höher rumfliegt, dann müsste man meistens so minus 50, 60 Grad.
Stimmt, die Flugzeuge bewegen sich im Prinzip so genau in diesem Grenzbereich. Minus 60 Grad, also da ist schon richtig kalt. Und dann kommt die Tropopause. Und was tut sich da mit der Temperatur?
Die bleibt dann über einen bestimmten Höhenbereich konstant.
Also es bleibt einfach kalt? Genau. Ja, und dann wird es wieder wärmer?
Genau, das hängt eben mit dieser Absorption des Sonnenlichts durch das Ozon zusammen.
Ah, verstehe. Und warum wird das Ozon jetzt da aktiv und nicht woanders? Also ist nur dort das Ozon, also das ist das, was man als die Ozonschicht versteht. Das heißt, dort sammelt sich das ganze Ozon. Weiß man auch, warum es sich genau dort sammelt und nicht irgendwo sonst?
Das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass man eben, um Ozon, das ist ja ein kontinuierlicher Prozess. In dieser Schicht wird Ozon erzeugt, Ozon zerstört und das ist im Endeffekt sollte in der Summe dann Null geben. Und damit ich das Sauerstoff, also Sauerstoff hängen ja zwei O-Moleküle aneinander.
O2?
O2, genau. Und um Ozon zu bilden, muss ich erstmal ein O2-Atom spalten und dann kann das frei gewordene O-Atom an Sauerstoff drangeben und dadurch bildet ich Ozon. Und dazu brauch ich eben auch sehr hochenergetische Strahlung. Und die hat man in der Höhe.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, dadurch, dass die Sonne an der Stelle das erste Mal auf so eine nennenswerte Dichte an Sauerstoff überhaupt trifft, unterstelle ich jetzt mal. Also vorher ist es sozusagen nicht dicht genug, sondern in dem Bereich ist dann einfach genug Sauerstoff da, dann trifft die Sonnenstrahlung auf und die erzeugt sozusagen das Ozon und das Ozon selbst absorbiert dann aber auch gleich wieder.
Und zerstört auch wieder Ozon und das ist so ein Prozess, der Null gibt.
Dann geben und nehmen. Und ein Nebeneffekt dabei ist, dass eben ein Großteil der Strahlung dadurch aber auch wiederum abgelenkt wird und die Erde quasi vor den Strahlen geschützt wird.
Genau, abgelenkt ist vielleicht nicht der richtige Ausdruck.
Sondern absorbiert?
Genau, absorbiert und durch diese Absorption erwärmt sich dann eben diese Schicht.
Das heißt, dann geht also die Temperatur wieder hoch. Aber auf was geht sie denn wieder hoch? Sind das jetzt nur ein paar Grad oder ist das irgendwie nennwert?
Das ist eine gute Frage, das weiß ich nicht auswendig. Da müsste ich nachschauen. Es liegt aber auch daran, weil Ozonschicht ist auch nicht mein Spezialgebiet.
Okay, gut, aber es geht dann wieder hoch. Und dann geht es aber irgendwann wieder runter, weil draußen ist ja kalt. Und das ist dann gleich da drüber?
Die Mesosphäre, die ist über der Stratosphäre. Und dazwischen ist natürlich wieder so eine Pause.
Das heißt, es gibt sozusagen eine relevante Schicht und dann ist erst mal Pause? Tropostratomeso und dann war es das schon. Thermo und dann Weltraum. Das heißt, wir haben sozusagen so vier wesentliche Atmosphärenbereiche.
Könnte man so sagen.
Zeichnet die Meso- und Thermosphäre, in der Thermosphäre wird es wieder wärmer, oder wie?
Genau, das liegt aber daran, dass einfach die Moleküle so weit auseinander sind, dass Temperatur in dem Sinn, wie wir es verstehen, nicht mehr gibt. Also Temperatur funktioniert ja auch dadurch, dass ich die braunste Molekularbewegung habe und sich Moleküle bewegen und wenn sie wärmer sind, können sie sich schneller bewegen und stoßen zusammen und geben dann quasi die Energie ab. Und in der Thermosphäre sind einfach die Moleküle so weit auseinander, dass es sehr lang dauert, bis die sich mal treffen und dadurch ihre Energie nicht so schnell abgeben können.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt, die Temperatur......ist nicht mehr so in unserem Sinne, Meister. Drückt sich anders aus auch und kann sich aber auch nicht so schnell verlieren, weil nicht so viel da ist, wo es sich hin verlieren kann. Jetzt hast du gesagt, die Schicht ist nicht so ganz dein Bereich. Welche Schicht ist in deinem Bereich?
Mein Bereich ist die Troposphäre.
Also wo sozusagen der Meteorologe sich auch zu Hause fühlt. Und was steht da so jetzt so in deinem Mittelpunkt?
In meinem Mittelpunkt sind die Aerosole, also unter Aerosole versteht man ein Gemisch aus Partikeln und der Luft. Partikel sind jetzt zum Beispiel Rußteilchen oder Staubteilchen oder Vulkanascherteilchen.
Und die sind einfach immer da oder ist das eher so ein sollte-nicht-auftauchen Effekt?
Doch, also es ist wichtig für die Strahlungsbilanz, dass die Aerosolpartikel da sind. Also ich kriege das Licht von der Sonne, die Strahlung, und wenn ich Aerosolpartikel da hab, führt das zum Teil dazu, dass das gar nicht den Erdboden erreicht, die Strahlung, weil es wieder in den Weltraum zurückgestreut wird. Wenn ich jetzt so eine ganz dicke Sulfatschicht, sagen wir mal, hätte, dann wird das meist gleich wieder zurück in den Weltraum gestreut und kommt am Boden gar nicht mehr so viel an. Wenn ich jetzt eine Rußschicht habe, dann wird auch ein Teil gestreut, aber ein Teil wird auch absorbiert von den Rußmolekülen und das führt dann dazu, dass die Rußschicht sich erwärmt. Und dadurch sehr interessante Effekte auf das Wetter haben kann.
Das heißt, Aerosole ist so ein Sammelbegriff für alle möglichen Sachen, die jetzt so chemisch nicht unmittelbar direkt was miteinander zu tun haben. Kann man das so sagen?
Wie meinst du das?
Sulfat, Ruß, das ist jetzt nicht alles dieselbe Kategorie chemisch, sondern im Wesentlichen zeichnet sich das aus, dass es irgendwie klein ist und in der Luft rumfliegt.
Ja, also mit dem chemischen nichts miteinander zu tun haben, da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil Aerosolpartikel können zum Beispiel zusammenstoßen oder auf ein Rußpartikel kann ein Ammonium-Sulfat- Schicht draufgehen und verändert das Partikel oder es können auch chemische Prozesse an den Oberflächen von Aerosolen ablaufen.
Also sie können miteinander reagieren, aber sie sind jetzt nicht alle von derselben Art.
Genau. Und das macht es auch so kompliziert, dass die nicht alle von derselben Art sind. Dadurch, dass ich zum Teil Staubteilchen habe und Sulfateilchen und Russteilchen, habe ich ganz viele verschiedene Größen von Partikeln. Die gehen von wenigen Nanometern bis einige 10, 20, 50 Mikrometer. Im Vergleich dazu das menschliche Hardendurchmesser von 100 Mikrometern. Und dann hat man eben nicht nur eine Sorte, dass man sagt, ich habe nur Ruspartikel, sondern ich habe auch Staub und was wir ja gerade diskutiert hatten. Dazu brauche ich relativ viele verschiedene Messgeräte, um das ganze Wesen von diesen Aerosolpartikeln zu erfassen, um den Größenbereich abzudecken, um herauszufinden, aus welchem Material sind sie zusammengesetzt. Das macht das Ganze auch so schwierig. Deswegen weiß man auch über Aerosolpartikel verglichen mit Spurngasen noch relativ wenig.
Die Atmosphäre setzt sich ja im Wesentlichen aus Luft zusammen, also aus Sauerstoff und Stickstoff. Und dann gibt es noch andere Dinge. Wie verteilt sich das so genau? Wie sind da jetzt die Größenordnungen, die man jetzt im Kopf haben sollte? Also vor allem Stickstoff.
Genau, wir haben 78 Prozent Stickstoff und 21 Prozent Sauerstoff. Und dann unter einem Prozent sind diese ganzen Spurngasen.
Also das ist schon 99 Prozent sozusagen. Und dann kommen die Spurngasen.
Genau, die heißen deswegen Spurngasen, weil sie nur in kleinen Spuren vorhanden sind. Da gehört zum Beispiel das CO2 dazu oder das Ozon oder das Lachgas.
Lachgas gibt es auch? Davon könnte man manchmal mehr gebrauchen.
So betrachtet schon im übertragenen Sinne.
Ja, hier im Raum ist gerade genug da. Und was noch an Spurngasen? Also CO2 hat man?
Es gibt noch das Methan. Es gibt noch sehr viele mehr. Aber die wichtigsten haben wir.
Und die sind gleichmäßig verteilt? Also sind die überall gleichmäßig dabei?
Sie sind mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig verteilt. Das liegt daran, also man hat natürlich bestimmte Regionen, wo man mehr Spurngase imitiert und Regionen, wo man weniger imitiert. Wenn man zum Beispiel mal annimmt, man hat eine Stadt, wo sehr viel Sprit verbrannt wird oder geheizt wird, da entsteht natürlich mehr CO2, als wenn ich irgendwo zum Beispiel in die Wüste gehe, wo ich nichts verbrenne. Aber die Lebenszeiten sind sehr lang von den Spurngasen. Also von CO2 100 Jahre, je nachdem welchen Aus-Prozess oder Ausentfernungsprozess ich habe. Und dadurch, wir haben ja einen Transport auf unserem Globus, die Winde wehen um den Globus rum und transportieren die Spurngase dann um die ganze Erde rum. Also erstmal um die Nordhemisphäre und dann auch im längeren Zeitraum um den ganzen Globus und das führt dazu, dass die relativ gleichmäßig verteilt sind.
Also alles kommt überall hin, über kurz oder lang.
Kann man so sagen.
Oder gibt es so tote Zonen, die von dem Rest nicht mitbekommen?
Nee, das kommt nie. Also in erster Linie geht natürlich erst auf einer Hemisphäre der Transport und dann im Laufe von Jahren geht das auch auf die Südhalbkugel, wenn jetzt irgendwas auf der Nordhalbkugel geht.
Und vice versa sozusagen. Das heißt, diese Spurngase sind eigentlich überall dasselbe. Es hängt bloß ab davon, ob es irgendwo ja nochmal explizit imitiert wird. CO2 ist eben das klassische Zivilisationsproblem, sag ich mal.
Nicht nur, ja.
Nicht nur, auch Methan.
Genau.
Das kommt aus den Kühen, ne?
Aus den Kühen oder es kann auch aus Böden kommen, wenn der Permafrost auftaut, kann Methan rauskommen. Es kann auch aus dem Meer kommen. Da gibt es diese Methangashydrate. Es gibt viele Quellen für das Methan.
Und wie sehr wird das gemessen? Ihr habt ja gesagt, im Institut wird das alles gesammelt. Jetzt wird man ja wohl nicht nur in München die Finger ausstrecken und mal gucken, wie es aussieht, sondern diese Messdaten müssen ja auch weltweit erfasst werden.
Genau, deswegen haben wir das Flugzeug. Und wir überlegen uns dann für so eine sogenannte Messkampagne gibt es verschiedene Fragestellungen. Also würde ich zum Beispiel herausfinden, wie viel Staub aus der Wüste kommt, dann würde ich bestimmte Messgeräte einbauen in das Flugzeug und fliege dann in die Wüste und mache Messungen. Das heißt, ich habe dann ein Loch in meinem Flugzeug, so einen Einlass, und da sauge ich die Luft ins Flugzeug rein und habe dann die verschiedensten Messgeräte in dem Flugzeug drinnen, wo ich dann zum Beispiel Partikel zählen könnte oder die Methangaskonzentration messen könnte oder die CO-Konzentration messen könnte.
Aber man fliegt ja jetzt nicht mit dem Flugzeug einmal im ganzen Planeten.
Nee, es ist immer eine Fragestellung. So eine Kampagne dauert in der Regel drei bis fünf Wochen. Und je nach Fragestellung geht man halt an den Ort, wo ich die Fragestellung am besten beantworten kann. Also wenn ich wissen will, wie viel Staub kommt aus der Wüste, dann gehe ich am besten in die Sahara, weil 60 Prozent der Staubemissionen aus der Sahara kommen. Wenn ich jetzt wissen will, wie viel Abgase aus einem Schiff rauskommen, dann gehe ich zum Beispiel in den Ärmelkanal und fliege dann in den Schiffsabgas rein und mache dann da Messungen. Und versuche auch, Messflüge zu wiederholen oder Flugmuster, damit man hinterher einen Vergleich hat. Also ich meine, wenn ich nur einmal durch einen Schiffsabgas zum Beispiel durchfliege, dann habe ich einen Datensatz. Und das ist ja eine Punktmessung. Ich will wissen, ob ich immer wieder das Gleiche beobachte. Deswegen wiederholt man dann diese Messflüge und macht, ja, fliegt er dann vielleicht 20 Mal in so einen Schiffsabgas rein und schaut, ob das immer gleich ist.
Das bezieht sich jetzt im Wesentlichen wieder auf diese Aerosol-Messung. Wir waren ja eben gerade nochmal so bei der Atmosphäre im Allgemeinen, CO2 etc., also was sich ja quasi global verteilt und auswirkt. Ich meine, gemessen wird ja sicherlich von vielen Institutionen rund um den Globus. Bekommt man diese Informationen alle? Also ist das sozusagen jetzt eine der Methoden, dass man sich einfach alles von jedem liefern lässt?
Ja, es gibt...
Fügt man alles, was man will?...
Kooperationen. Das funktioniert in meinem Bereich sehr gut und ich denke auch in anderen Bereichen. Es gibt auch koordinierte Messkampagnen, dass man mit mehreren Flugzeugen aus verschiedensten Ländern an einen Ort geht und zum Beispiel ein Thema untersucht. Vor zwei Jahren hatten wir eine Kampagne in Grünland, wo wir uns angeschaut haben, wie viel Waldbrandemissionen von kanadischen und sibirischen Waldbränden in die Arktis transportiert werden. Da war noch ein Flugzeug von den Franzosen da. Und es waren amerikanische Flugzeuge beteiligt, die wirklich in der Nähe der Brände gemessen haben. Und dann hatten wir hinterher einen riesigen Datensatz, der einen direkt an der Quelle, wir haben einige tausend Kilometer weg von der Quelle gemessen und man vergleicht das dann. Und damit hat man auch die beste Chance, am meisten herauszubekommen über die Waldbrände und wie das funktioniert.
Ja, jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip schon mitten so in dieser Fragestellung, was ist das Ergebnis dieser Untersuchung. Wenn man also jetzt, ich will nicht fragen, was ist interessanter, interessant ist natürlich alles. Aber es hat ja jetzt unterschiedliche Aspekte. Also dieser CO2-Anteil, zum Beispiel ist ja nun auch der Methan-Anteil, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, ist ja so ein wesentliches Zentrum der Debatte um den Klimawandel. Diese Aerosole, weiß ich nicht, ob die da in dem Zusammenhang auch eine Rolle spielen oder ist das jetzt eher so klassische Umweltverschmutzung?
Nee, die spielen auch eine große Rolle. Ich glaube einfach, das ist nur in der Öffentlichkeit nicht so bekannt, da ist vor allem das CO2 eben als mit Treibhauseffekt bekannt. Aber zum Beispiel Rußpartikel stehen im Verdacht, nach CO2 am zweitstärksten zur globalen Erwärmung beizutragen. Der große Unterschied zwischen dem Ruß und dem CO2 ist vor allem die Lebenszeit. Also der Ruß, der ist nicht so lange in der Atmosphäre, weil diese Aerosolpartikel als Wolkenkondensationskeime dienen. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Wassertröpfchen bilden will oder eine Wolke, dann brauch ich immer ein kleines Partikel, auf dem das Wassertröpfchen entsteht. Und wenn das Rußpartikel dann quasi als Wolkenkondensation Keim gedient hat, dann wird sie im Regen ausgewaschen und geht dann deswegen schneller wieder aus der Atmosphäre raus.
Also hat das eine geringere Halbwertszeit?
Genau, eine kürzere Lebenszeit.
Aber es spielt trotzdem eine Rolle?
Ja.
Also auch eine messbare, nachweisbare Rolle?
Genau, das ist eine der großen Fragen, wie ist die Rolle des Russers, die momentan sehr aktuell ist und wo es viele Messungen gibt und wo auch dann die Daten benutzt werden, die bei diesen Messungen entstehen, um damit zu rechnen. Also eine interessante Fragestellung ist zum Beispiel auch, was würde es bringen, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel die Rußemissionen reglementiere? Hat man dann wirklich einen Effekt oder nicht?
Also auch im Verkehr spielt es eine Rolle. Verbrennung, Motoren etc. Also der Mensch produziert eine Menge Ruß, kann man sagen. Ja. Jetzt hast du eben schon gesagt, Sand aus der Sahara. Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt nicht ganz so manmade.
Das stimmt, also man geht davon aus, dass die Staubemissionen aus der Sahara einen gewissen menschengemachten Anteil haben, der zwischen 0 und 20 Prozent liegt.
Ach, wie das?
Wenn ich als Mensch natürlich das Klima verändere, führt das dazu, dass ich vielleicht größere Trockenzonen kriege. Oder wenn ich sehr intensiv Landwirtschaft betreibe, dann können es eben sein, dass man mehr Erosionen kriegt.
Also dass der Mensch zur Ausbreitung der Wüsten beiträgt. Und dadurch, dass einfach mehr Wüste da ist, gibt es dann auch mehr Partikelausstoß. Also was heißt Staub? Wir reden jetzt quasi vom Sandabrieb.
Genau, Sand ist ja das, was man im Sandkasten hat. Aber diese Staubteilchen, die transportiert werden über längere Strecken, die sind in der Regel kleiner als 10 Mikrometer. Wenn man noch mal den Vergleich mit dem Haar hat, das hat einen Durchmesser von 100 Mikrometer. Also das ist sehr viel kleiner als das, was man im Sandkasten sieht. Nichtsdestotrotz, wenn ich mal so einen massiven Staubausbruch hab, was ja öfters mal vorkommt, dass der Staub aus der Sahara zu uns her transportiert wird, kann man manchmal auf Autos und auf Fenstersimsen draußen so eine feine Schicht Staubschicht beobachten.
Das kommt dann aus der Sahara? Soweit schlägt das? Und wie lange ist das unterwegs?
Das ist von der Wetterlage abhängig. Ich würde jetzt mal so sagen, mehr als zwei bis fünf Tage, sechs Tage.
Also was bedingt diesen Ausbruch? Also Sandstürme, oder sind das noch andere Faktoren, die als eine Rolle spielen?
Ja, es gibt verschiedene Staubmobilisierungsmechanismen. Einer ist einfach, wenn ich eine bestimmte Windgeschwindigkeit am Boden habe, das kann man sich ganz leicht vorstellen, wenn ich am Sandkasten darüber blas, mit einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit, dann werden Sandpartikel in die Luft imitiert. Und das ist ein Mechanismus, wie das in die Atmosphäre kommt. Und das andere ist eben mit sogenannten dichte Strömungen, dass man aus Wolken ausfließende Kaltluft hat, die dann sehr viel Staub mobilisieren kann.
Staub, Ruß, was sind jetzt noch weitere Kandidate?
Zum Beispiel ein wichtiger Partikeltyp oder auch Seesalz. Ein ganz großer Anteil des Aerosols in der Atmosphäre ist Seesalz auch.
Ja, vielleicht bleiben wir einfach mal bei den, jetzt haben wir es auch schon ein paar Mal gesagt, die Sache mit den Vulkanen. Vulkanen aus Brüche gibt es immer wieder. Ich weiß nicht, wie häufig das eigentlich so ist pro Jahr.
Im Durchschnitt einen pro Woche.
Ach echt? Einen pro Woche? So richtig mit Rauch und Tralala? Oder wo überhaupt ein bisschen Lava fließt? Macht das keinen großen Unterschied?
Rauch und Lava. Wobei viele von diesen Vulkanen im indonesischen Raum sind, so dass wir das nicht so mitbekommen.
Ah, das ist sozusagen das Vulkanzentrum.
Genau.
Und was, das heißt jede Woche kümmert ihr euch auch um die Ergebnisse, die das jeweils bringt? Oder ist das nur selten ein Thema?
Also es war vor allem letztes Jahr ein Thema, weil eben dieser Vulkan in Island, der Eyjafjallajökull, so riesige Aschewolken ausgestoßen hat, die dann unseren Flugverkehr massiv eingeschränkt haben. Das haben wir alle mitgekriegt. Die Flugzeuge standen am Boden, die reisen dann auch. Und da war das ein richtig großes Thema für uns.
Was ist da passiert? Also klar, der Vulkan ist erstmal ausgebrochen und hat, ich weiß nicht, war das jetzt irgendwie ein besonders überdurchschnittlicher Ausbruch? Man sah sehr imposant aus.
Eigentlich war es sogar eher ein unterdurchschnittlicher Ausbruch verglichen mit einem riesigen Ausbruch vom Pinatubo im Jahr 1991. Der Unterschied zu diesen ganz großen Ausbrüchen, die dann auch längere Zeit auf die Atmosphäre und auf das Klima wirken, ist, dass bei dem Eyjafjallajökull ist die Asche nicht in die Stratosphäre imitiert worden, sondern ist nur in der Troposphäre oder nur geringe Mengen sind in die Stratosphäre gegangen. Wir haben ja vorher gesagt, in der Troposphäre findet das Wetter statt und da werden die Aerosolpartikel auch wieder schneller ausgewaschen. Wenn ich jetzt einen Vulkanausbruch habe, der die Partikel bis in die Stratosphäre imitiert, da ist eben dann dieser Auswaschprozess durch die Wolken nicht mehr da. Das heißt, da bleibt die Asche relativ lange in der Stratosphäre und kann dann auch eine richtig große Klimawirkung entfalten. Im Fall des Pinatubo 1991 hat der Ausbruch dazu geführt, dass man am Boden auf der Nordhemisphäre eine Abkühlung von ungefähr 0,4 bis 0,6 Grad beobachtet hat und sogar einige Jahre lang den Effekt von diesem Vulkan gesehen hat.
Weltweit oder im Mittel oder in einer bestimmten Region?
Weltweit war der Effekt 0,5 Grad auf der Nordhemisphäre ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist ja schon erheblich.
Ja, da haben wir auch wieder den Transport, den wir vorher schon angesprochen haben. Wenn ich das in die Atmosphäre emittiere und eben nicht auswasche durch die Wolken, dann wird das mit der Zeit verteilt. Erst auf der Hemisphäre, aus der es emittiert wurde, und dann über beide Hemisphären.
Das heißt, große Ausbrüche wie der von Pinatubo sind jetzt eher seltener Ereignisse.
Das sind eher selten, ja.
Das heißt, selten gerät die Asche wirklich einmal in 100 Jahren.
Also der Pinatubo-Ausbruch war so einmal in 100 Jahren Ereignis.
Oha, wenn man das 91, ja. Das heißt, da ist es mal ein bisschen die Stratosphäre vorgedrungen. Das heißt, normalerweise passiert das nicht.
Es gab auch noch andere Vulkanausbrüche, den El Chikon, das weiß ich aber nicht, wann das genau war. Also auch in den vergangenen Jahren gab es auch noch andere Vulkanausbrüche, die bis in die Stratosphäre gingen.
Und das heißt, normalerweise bleibt alles in der Troposphäre?
Was heißt normalerweise?
Na ja, ich meine, wenn nur alle 100 Jahre das jetzt so weit hochgeht, aber es einmal die Woche einen gibt, dann würde ich jetzt mal sagen...
Moment, da muss man vielleicht nochmal klarstellen, dass der Pinatubo so stark ausbricht, wie er 1991 ausgebrochen ist, das passiert einmal in 100 Jahren.
Ach so, nur in Bezug auf den Pinatubo?
Genau.
Alles klar, verstehe. Okay, das heißt, es geschieht schon häufiger, dass die Asche bis in die Stratosphäre geht?
Ja, genau, da habe ich mich vorher missverständlich ausgebildet.
Aber jetzt in Island war das gar nicht so.
Ist das meiste in der Troposphäre geblieben.
Und dann würde man ja meinen, dass das Problem sich dann auch schnell wieder löst?
Hat sich ja auch schnell wieder gelöst. Nach zwei Monaten oder so war der Spuck vorbei.
Trotzdem war der Aufschrei jetzt relativ groß. Was war denn jetzt sozusagen das Besondere an dieser Situation?
Der Grund, der da das Problem verursacht hat, hat man Vulkanasche steht in dem Verdacht, dass Flugzeugtriebwerke geschädigt werden können, weil die Asche einen sehr niedrigen Schmelzpunkt hat. Das heißt, es kann im Triebwerk schmelzen und dann Löcher verstopfen und im schlimmsten Fall kann das Triebwerk von dem Flugzeug ausgehen. Und das ist dann nicht so gemütlich.
Und ist jetzt besonders viel von dieser Asche dort frei geworden? Also war das jetzt irgendwie auch noch ein besonders massiver Ausbruch, unabhängig davon, dass das jetzt nicht so hoch geschafft hat? Also wie viel Gramm? Viel ist ja immer relativ, genau.
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf hab, sind 10 Millionen Tonnen Asche ausgestoßen worden.
Und da gab es ja erstmal eine extreme Verunsicherung. Also so wie ich das gehört habe, es gab wohl auch mal einen Fall, wo das passiert ist mit einem Flugzeug.
Ja, das war Anfang der 80er Jahre eine KLM-Maschine.
In Indien oder so?
In Indonesien, glaube ich. Aber das muss man nochmal nachschauen.
Und da ist genau das passiert?
Genau. Und die hatten einfach Glück, dass sie in sehr großer Höhe waren und das Triebwerk wieder anbekommen haben.
Aha.
Als die in die Asche, in die Wolke eingeflogen waren nur ein paar Sekunden drinnen. Und sind dann wieder rausgeflogen mit stehendem Triebwerk und haben das dann wieder anbekommen.
Aber seitdem geht die Angst um, sozusagen?
Ja, man hat dann in der Luftfahrt die Regeln vereinbart, wenn ein Partikel Asche in der Luft ist, dann darf er dann nicht mehr geflogen werden bei uns.
Und durch den Ausbruch in Island zog aber jetzt die ganze Wolke dann auch noch richtig schön nach Mitteleuropa?
Genau. Wir hatten einfach da eine Wetterlage, die sehr günstig war für den Transport von diesen Ascheschichten nach Europa.
Wie ist denn das so? Habt ihr da auch so Feuerwehr-mäßig solche Stangen im ersten Stock? Und wenn Ascherausbruch ist, setzt man sich schnell einen Helm auf und muss schnell agieren? Also es gab ja da einige Aktivität beim DLR aufgrund dieser Fluggeschichte. Was ist denn da noch passiert?
Wir haben keine Stangen. Das ist ja auch eine Forschungseinrichtung. Und wie wir vorher schon besprochen haben, wir haben eher diese Messkampagnen, die man lange im Voraus plant. Dann überlegt man sich, welche Messgeräte baue ich ein und dann so einen Einbau, der dauert dann ungefähr ein bis zwei Wochen. Dann habe ich meistens einen Testflug, wo ich schaue, ob alles geht, ob die Leitungen, die ich vor meinem Einlass reingelegt habe, ob die dicht sind und ob alle Messgeräte funktionieren. Normalerweise hatten wir dann ziemlich langen Vorlauf. Das war bei dem Fall des Island-Volkanes nicht der Fall. Der ist ja dann am 14. April ausgebrochen. Es war dann ziemlich schnell klar, dass die erste Wolke Richtung Europa, Zentraleuropa zieht. Wir haben dann am 16. April beschlossen, dass wir messen wollen. Das war ein Freitagnachmittag. Wir haben dann angefangen, die Leute zusammen zu trommeln und die Messgeräte aufzubauen in einer ziemlich hektischen Aktion. Aber es war insofern eine tolle Erfahrung, weil alle so gut zusammen gearbeitet haben. Jeder hat seinen Part gemacht und es ist eigentlich das Unmögliche möglich gemacht worden, diesen Flieger innerhalb von drei Tagen zu bestücken. Und dann an dem Montag, also Freitag, haben wir angefangen, die Geräte zusammenzubauen. Am Montag haben wir einen Messflug gehabt, ohne Testflug, ohne die Vorbereitung, die wir sonst hatten.
Das heißt, normalerweise würde man Wochen dafür einplanen?
Genau. Und auch um die Geräte zuzulassen. Also das ist alles innerhalb dieses Wochenendes abgelaufen.
Also es gab ja in den Medien erst mal diesen klassischen uninformierten Aufschrei, so, ja, wie ihr wisst jetzt gar nicht, was los ist. Es gibt jetzt kein Vulkan-Asche-Warnsystem, wo überall Messstationen stehen und wenn dann so ein Ding ausbricht, dann weiß man sofort, dass man die Flugzeuge am Boden lassen soll. Sondern es war insofern eine sehr besondere Situation, weil die viel zu selten ist, als dass man sich da auf regelmäßiger Basis für vorbereiten kann.
Das stimmt so gar nicht mal. Es gibt diese WAAC-Zentren, also Volcanic Ash Advisory Centers. Da sitzt eins in London und da werden Vulkane überwacht und die haben auch einen Notfallplan, wo sie dann eben auch ein Modell haben, mit dem sie rechnen, wo geht die Asche hin und dann für weitere Aktionen wie Luftraumschließungen die Daten bereitstellen.
Und? Das hat aber nicht gereicht? Oder was war das Problem?
Naja, die haben die Rechnungen gemacht und daraufhin ist der Luftraum geschlossen worden. Und es war ja auch ein Kritikpunkt, dass keine Messungen gibt, sondern nur Modellrechnungen. Und das stimmt so auch nicht, weil es gibt am Boden sehr viele Leader-Stationen, unter anderem das ÖLiNet. Das ist so ein Verbund von Leader-Stationen und mit dem Leader hat man ja vorher schon erwähnt, ich schau mit schießenden Laserstrahlen die Atmosphäre und aufgrund der Laufzeit des Lichtes kann ich dann sagen, in welcher Höhe ich Schichten habe. Und da hat man sehr gut gesehen, wie die Ascheschicht reingegangen ist. Die Uni München war da sehr führend auch. Die haben von Anfang an gemessen und man sieht dann sehr schön in den Daten von denen, dass diese Ascheschicht in der Nacht vom 16. auf 17. April angekommen ist in München und zuerst in größerer Höhe war und dann abgesunken ist und sie war ungefähr so 500 Meter dick.
Das heißt, man hat schon die Möglichkeit vom Boden auch aus zu messen. Es gibt nicht überall diese Mess-Methoden oder das entsprechende Gerät, sondern nur vereinzelt und am idealsten ist die Kombination von dem LIDAR.
Ja, mit dem LIDAR sehe ich halt die vertikale Struktur recht gut. Was ich nicht weiß, ich kann nicht direkt aus der LIDAR Messung abschätzen, wie viele Milligramm Asche pro Kubikmeter habe ich jetzt da vorliegen. Da brauche ich Umrechnungsfaktoren.
Man sieht sozusagen auf der Breite, da ist was und es befindet sich auf der und der Höhe. Das ist so eine Art Laserscanner. Es wird sozusagen breitflächig der Himmel abgetastet.
Das ist ein dünner Laserstrahl, der nach oben geht. Manche LIDARs können auch scannen oder schauen dann unter bestimmten Winkeln raus und man kriegt dann eben so ein Vertikalprofil.
Das heißt, die Partikel, die reflektieren diesen Laser und darauf auf der Basis kann man das dann ausrechnen.
Das Licht vom Laser, ja.
Und die LMU hat sowas? Wer verfügt noch über solche?
Das Institut für Troposphärenforschung in Leipzig hat so ein LIDAR-System, ziemlich gutes. In Hamburg gibt es eins. Wir sind dann bei unserem ersten Messflug über ziemlich viele LIDAR-Systeme in Deutschland drübergeflogen, unter anderem in München, in Leipzig, in Hamburg, in Stuttgart, in Jülich. Wir waren dann auch noch in den Niederlanden, in Kabao und haben dann versucht, dadurch, dass wir an den Stationen, wo eben BodennIDAR-Messungen da sind, dann auch noch durchfliegen, durch die Asche Wolken, dann Partikel zählen und dann Daten liefern für diesen Umrechnungsfaktor aus den LIDAR-Daten in Masse.
Das heißt, man hat auch die Gelegenheit genutzt, das sozusagen zu kombinieren. Man sagt, so sieht es von unten aus, so misst es sich oben. Jetzt kann man diese Daten auch mal miteinander vergleichen, ob man auch irgendwelche Schlüsse draus ziehen kann, dass man später sagen kann, okay, jetzt haben wir jetzt zwar keinen Messflug, aber auf Basis der Daten, so wie sich es da mal verhalten hat, könnte das das bedeuten.
Das ist auch so ein Ziel gewesen, von dieser Messkampagne zu untersuchen, wie verändert sich die Vulkanasche, wenn sie älter wird? Muss ich zum Beispiel diesen Umrechnungsfaktor, ist das immer der gleiche oder ist das ein anderer, also der verändert sich zum Beispiel mit dem Alter. Von dem her wird es auch in Zukunft wichtig sein, zumindest ein paar Mal durchzufliegen und dann genau zu zählen, wie viele Partikel da sind und dann die Messers zu retten.
Das heißt, man wusste zwar, die Aschewolke ist da, an den Orten, wo man das mit dem Laser messen konnte, aber man wusste nicht wirklich, wie dicht ist sie wirklich, wie groß ist dieses Problem wirklich und da gibt es eigentlich auch gar keine Möglichkeit, das vom Boden aus zu machen. Das heißt, dieses Vulkanasche, wie hieß das gleich noch, das Zentrum, Vulkanasche-Advisory-Centrum, die waren sozusagen darauf vorbereitet zu sagen, ok, da gibt es jetzt einen Vulkanausbruch und wir haben jetzt hier diese meteorologischen Flussdaten und wir können daraufhin schnell mal mathematisch ein Modell erstellen und sagen, unserer Meinung nach wird es sich so und so ausbreiten und so hat es dann wahrscheinlich auch getan.
Genau, das hat recht gut gestimmt.
Man hat vielleicht ein Problem und zwar wahrscheinlich dort und mit den LIDAR-Messungen könnte man sagen, okay, alles klar, das ist jetzt auch da, wir können es sehen oder abtasten, aber es fehlt immer noch die konkrete Information. Wie viele Einrichtungen gibt es, die solche Messflüge jetzt durchführen können?
Also es gibt in Deutschland oder in Europa?
Ich weiß nicht überhaupt so.
Also es gibt verschiedenste Forschungsflüge oder Forschungseinrichtungen, die Messflugzeuge betreiben. Es gab in den ersten Tagen in der Schweiz schon einen, der mit einem Motorsiegler geflogen ist und Messungen gemacht hat. Er kam aber nur bis, glaube ich, drei Kilometer Höhe. Und die Ascherschicht war zum Teil in größerer Höhe. Dann die britischen Kollegen haben Messflüge gemacht. Die französischen Kollegen dann auch. Die waren aber dann später dran als wir. Das ist der Vorteil von unseren Messflügen.
Nur so eins pro Land kann man jetzt sagen. Also es gibt gar nicht so viel. Das ist nicht so, dass jetzt jeder Uni noch so einen Flieger rumstehen hat.
Nein, das stimmt.
Falkon ist in dem Sinne eine seltene Angelegenheit.
Ja, schon ziemlich einzigartig, das stimmt. Und es hat sich auch rumgesprochen, dass wir ziemlich gute Messungen gemacht haben, was dann dazu geführt haben, dass verschiedene Länder uns angefordert haben, zu messen, wie die Aschekonzentration in deren Luftraum ist. Es gab Anfragen von Italien und Spanien. Und es gab auch eine von Island direkt zu messen, wie viel aus dem Vulkan rauskommt. Und wir können natürlich nicht überall gleichzeitig hinfliegen, aber wir sind dann nach Island geflogen und haben dann Messungen gemacht des Massenflusses. Also wie viel kommt aus dem Vulkan direkt raus? Weil das ist nämlich der wichtige Parameter, den ich in mein Modell reinstecken muss. Ich meine, mit dem Modell kann ich sagen, wie stark es sich ausbreitet. Und wenn ich mit aus dem Modell eine Konzentration bestimmen will, dann muss ich natürlich einen richtigen Quelltherm reinstecken. Also wie viel geht aus dem Vulkan raus und wie stark wird es verteilt. Und wenn dieser Quelltherm nicht stimmt, dann stimmt auch die Konzentration nicht, die ich mit dem Modell ausrechne. Und das ist ja bei Vulkanen sehr schwierig, weil die sich von Tag zu Tag ändern können, diese Quellstärken.
Vielleicht jetzt nochmal zum zeitlichen Ablauf. Also 14. April war der Ausbruch.
Genau.
Und dann war relativ schnell klar, es könnte ein Problem geben, weil da ist viel Asche, offensichtlich. Also man saß ja, es hat ja gequempt wie ein Schlot. Und zusätzlich mit diesen frühen Modellrechnungen könnte man so die Aussage machen, dass so viel wieder rauskommt, das wird bestimmt ein Problem sein. Aber könnte man aus diesen Modellrechnungen auch schon die Vorhersage machen, in welchen Höhen es sich ausbreiten wird? Ist das sozusagen so Teil dieser Modellrechnung?
Das Modell kann schon eine Höhenabhängigkeit oder ausrechnen, in welcher Höhe das wahrscheinlich sein wird. Aber das hängt auch davon ab, wie gut das Modell in der Vertikalen aufgelöst ist. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel das Modell nur alle 100 Meter einen Gitterpunkt hat und die Ascheschicht jetzt 50 Meter dick wäre, dann wird das ausgeschmiert von dem Modell. Bis zum gewissen Grad kann man die Höhenabhängigkeit vorhersagen, aber nicht in dem Detail, wie es zum Beispiel dann ein Liter messen könnte.
Aber was führt denn jetzt wirklich dazu, dass die Asche so und so hochgeht? Ist das jetzt eine rein meteorologische Frage, wie die Atmosphäre zu dem Zeitpunkt gerade beschaffen ist, ob sie das automatisch nach oben leitet durch Thermiken oder hat das auch was mit der schieren Masse an Material zu tun oder sogar auch mit der Ausstoßgeschwindigkeit? Also ist das so ein Düseneffekt, dass der Vulkan es auch schon auf den ersten Metern so weit hochpresst, dass es klar ist, dass das muss jetzt erstmal eine Weile fliegen, bevor das vor den Schichten beeinflusst wird? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also es sind natürlich mehrere Faktoren. Der wichtigste ist natürlich schon, wie stark die Explosion, sag ich jetzt mal, an dem Vulkan selber...
Das ist der wichtigste Faktor.
Ja, und dann natürlich auch die Schichtung der Atmosphäre, wie hoch das gehen kann. Was in Island dazu geführt hat, dass so viel Asch herauskam, hing auch damit zusammen, dass man ja das Eis auf dem Berg drauf hat und dann das Schmelzwasser, was dann sehr stark dazu führt, dass man sehr viel Asche emittieren kann.
Ah, das heißt also der Vulkan hat quasi das Eis gelöst durch seine Hitze?
Ja, genau, das ist geschmolzen und dann...
Das kam dann noch mit rein.
Genau, das ist so zusätzlicher Wasserdampf, der dann natürlich sofort verdampft und sehr viel Energie auch freisetzt.
Und deswegen war das jetzt so ein fetter Strahl, der da abgelöst wurde und dann blieb aber trotzdem alles in der Troposphäre. Das meiste. Und das war aber jetzt sozusagen das, was besonders schlecht war, weil sich der Flugverkehr ja dort abspielt.
Besonders schlecht, besonders gut. Es kommt immer auf den Standpunkt an. Von dem, was man betrachtet aus der Klimasicht, war es vielleicht besser, dass es nicht in die Stratosphäre gegangen ist.
Ich habe das jetzt sozusagen in Bezug auf den Flugverkehr, weil ich meine, das war ja die große Aufregung.
Gut, ich meine, das ist ja bei anderen Vulkanen auch so. Selbst wenn das bis in die Stratosphäre geht, kommen in niedrigeren Höhen ja dann auch Partikel in die Atmosphäre. Wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal an so Bilder erinnert, da ist jetzt in Indonesien ein Vulkan ausgebrochen, da ist eine riesige Asche, Wolke, die da rausgeht. Ein Teil geht natürlich dann oben in die Stratosphäre, ein Teil in die Troposphäre und beeinflusst den Flugverkehr.
Okay, also auch wenn es höher geht, die Troposphäre ist eigentlich immer betroffen. Aber hier war es so, dass mehr oder weniger, was weiß ich, 95 Prozent der Masse dann auch dort gelandet ist, wo es besonders viele Auswirkungen auf den Flugverkehr hat, unabhängig jetzt vom Klima. Und wann war klar, dass es dann zum Einsatz kommen würde?
Also wir haben, wie gesagt, an dem 14., an dem 16., hatten wir unsere ersten Diskussionen, dass wir eigentlich Messflüge machen sollten. Und dann war am Anfang nicht klar, ob das überhaupt so schnell geht.
Da gab es aber noch keine Anfragen, oder?
Nein, wir wollten das zuerst. Aber das hat dann auch eine Dynamik angenommen.
Aber eigentlich hatte der was anderes vor. Also ihr müsstet sozusagen eine andere Testserie dann erstmal abbrechen.
Wir hatten sehr viele andere Sachen vor, ja. Was dazu geführt hat, dass zum Teil die Messgeräte, die werden immer in so einen Rack eingebaut. Also das ist so ein Eisengestell, sag ich jetzt mal, wo die fest verschraubt sind, dass die im Flugzeug nicht hin und her fallen, die Messgeräte. Und ja, das muss man erst alles zusammenbauen, weil wir eben nicht damit gerechnet haben, dass wir eine spontane Messkampagne haben werden.
Ja, ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass es da natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit gleich so eine Schreierei gab. Ja, warum weiß denn keiner Bescheid? Ja, also der Politik wurde ja gleich vorgeworfen, wer nicht, was weiß ich, nicht an uns fähig. Aber das Problem ist, so ein Flugzeug ist nicht immer in der Lage, alles Mögliche zu messen, sondern man muss es eben genau mit, also auf die jeweilige Mission abgestimmt ausrüsten.
Genau, und der zweite wichtige Punkt ist, der Flieger steht nicht voll bestückt da, sondern der ist leer. Und ich muss erst alles einbauen und ich muss dann Leitungen legen zu meinen Messgeräten. Wenn ich nämlich in großer Höhe rumfliege, dann habe ich ja außen draußen sehr viel niedrigeren Druck. 200 Hektopascal vielleicht so in 10 Kilometer Höhe. Und im Flugzeug habe ich ja meine Druckkabine so 750 Hektopascal. Das heißt, ich muss dafür sorgen, dass meine Rohrleitungen dicht sind. Dass ich wirklich nur die Partikel messe, die draußen sind und nicht das, was im Flugzeug drinnen ist. Und das führt dazu, dass wir Edelstahlrohre vom Einlass zu den Messgeräten verlegen, die dann mit so einem Patentsystem verschraubt werden, das dann druckdicht ist, damit man eben nicht die Luft aus der Kabine misst. Und das ist ziemlich aufwendig, diese ganzen Leitungen zu verlegen. Ich glaube, wir hatten 14 Aerosol-Messgeräte an Bord.
Die Leitungen müssen auch immer wieder neu verlegt werden.
Genau, weil die Rex zum Teil an verschiedenen Positionen stehen im Flugzeug. Und dann ist man mal kurzfristig ein Klempner und biegt Rohrleitungen, macht Verschraubungen.
Diese Falcon, was ist das eigentlich für ein Flugzeug?
Eine Falcon 20E von Dassault.
So, und die ist speziell umgebaut. Also sie ist sozusagen dafür vorgesehen, dass man alles Mögliche einbauen kann.
Genau, sie hat zum Beispiel Positionen im Dach, wo ich ein Loch machen kann und dann diesen Einlass reinbauen kann. Oder sie hat im Boden Teile, die man rausschrauben kann, wo man dann so ein Liederfenster einbauen kann. Das muss man alles erst machen.
Verstehe. Also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich nur so eine nackte Plattform, in der man alles installieren kann. Aber man muss es eben auch alles erst installieren. Und das ist eigentlich ein Prozess, der sehr sorgfältig geplant werden muss, weil was kommt wohin, da, da, da. Das ist ein notwendiger Material. Und das dann innerhalb von zwei, drei Tagen durchzuführen, war schon etwas stressiger.
Kann man so sagen. Aber es macht natürlich auch Spaß. Der Wissenschaftler will natürlich irgendwas messen und es war eine ganz tolle Atmosphäre eigentlich. Aber auch sehr anstrengend.
Was musste denn jetzt konkret eigentlich an Messgeräten dort installiert werden? Also was wurde denn gemessen?
Also wir haben das ganze Größenspektrum an Aerosolpartikeln gemessen von wenigen Nanometern bis, ja, mehrere bis 50 Mikrometer ungefähr. Dann haben wir ein Messgerät für CO eingebaut. Dann hatten wir ein Messgerät für Wasserdampf, für Temperaturmessungen, ist sowieso immer dabei auf der Falcon. Ja. Wir wollten, CO ist ein sogenannter Tracer, also ein Marker für Emissionen, zum Beispiel anthropogene Emissionen. Was wir dann auch festgestellt haben, dass aus dem Vulkan auch sehr viel CO rauskommt, das war uns vorher nicht so klar. Ich will ja auch trennen, wenn ich eine ganz dünne Ascheschicht habe, die ich zum Beispiel nicht mehr mit dem Auge sehen kann, dann will ich auch noch Messgeräte haben, die mir sagen können, woher das sonst noch kommen könnte. Dann hatten wir ein Messgerät dabei für die SO2-Konzentration. SO2 kommt ja auch in sehr großen Masen aus Vulkanen heraus.
Genau.
Dann hatten wir Messgeräte für die großen Partikel. Das sind riesige Sonden, ungefähr 1,5 Meter lang, die unter die Flügel geschraubt werden vom Flugzeug. Dann hatten wir Probensammler, wo man auf so einem kleinen Gitter die Partikel sammelt und hinterher im Labor analysieren kann. Da kann man dann was rausfinden über die chemische Zusammensetzung, über die Form der Partikel. Das ist auch sehr wichtig. Dann hatten wir eins der wichtigsten Instrumente, das war auch das LIDAR. Wir hatten ein Wind-LIDAR-System dabei, mit dem man zum einen die Windgeschwindigkeit und Windrichtung messen konnte, aber eben auch die Aerosol-Schichten sehen konnte. Das war für uns sehr wichtig, weil wir erstmal über die Ascherschicht drüber geflogen sind und uns dann angeschaut haben, wie dick ist sie denn? Kann man da reinfliegen oder kann man da nicht reinfliegen? Wir sind natürlich auch nicht in die dickste Ascherschicht reingeflohen. Wir wollten uns ja nicht gefährden.
Das Problem gibt es natürlich auch noch. Man kann mit dem LIDAR die Windgeschwindigkeit messen, indem man jetzt sozusagen die Geschwindigkeit der auf einem zufliegenden Partikel misst.
Genau, das ist ein sehr ausgefuchstes Verfahren, mit dem man die Windgeschwindigkeit messen kann. Ja, das zum Beispiel auch.
Das ist dann sehr akkurat, oder?
Ja, und das ist eigentlich ein Verfahren, das auch für einen Satelliten entwickelt wurde und wird, wo das DLR sehr führend ist mit dieser Messmethodik.
Aber ich meine, nicht weil jetzt der Satellit die Windgeschwindigkeit um ihn herum messen muss?
Nee, sondern die Windgeschwindigkeit in der Atmosphäre.
Ah ja, indem man von oben schaut und sieht, wie sich...
Genau, das ist der ADM Eolus von der ESA.
Und das ist dann auch sehr akkurat.
Also der fliegt noch nicht, aber der wird in Zukunft fliegen.
Der wird fliegen. Also das ist schon on track das Projekt. Das wird stattfinden. So, und dann ging es hoch nachdem alles eingebaut wurde. Zunächst einmal über Deutschland.
Genau, über Deutschland und Niederlande. Und bei dem ersten Messflug, da wussten wir auch noch nicht so genau, was auf uns zukommt. Es gab natürlich die einen Leute, die gesagt haben, es sei alles überhaupt kein Problem. Und es gab dann auch andere, die gesagt haben, seid vorsichtig. Und wir haben uns dann einen Plan überlegt, wie man das am besten machen könnte, ohne dass wir uns gefährden oder andere gefährden. Wir wussten aus den Lila-Messungen, dass die Schicht über München nur 500 Meter dick ist. Da kann man sehr schnell durchfliegen. Und wir haben dann beschlossen, erst einmal drüber zu fliegen und dann zu schauen, wie dick ist die Arschenschicht. Und dann in der Nähe von Flughäfen reinzufliegen. Das haben wir dann in der Nähe von München, in der Nähe von Leipzig, in der Nähe von Cabau, in der Nähe von Stuttgart gemacht. Und so haben wir von Messflug zu Messflug mehr Erfahrung bekommen. Was verträgt unser Flieger? Wie wirkt sich das aus?
Nicht ohne Risiko.
Ja, Forschung ist nie ohne Risiko.
Ich meine, da war ja sonst kein Flieger oben.
Ja, wir haben natürlich auch sehr viel Erfahrung aus diesen Messungen in der Sahara und haben gesagt, wir machen nur Konzentrationen, die wir in der Sahara auch gemessen haben. Und wir waren uns sicher, dass das kein Risiko ist, weil sonst hätten wir es ja nicht gemacht.
Ja. Und was war denn jetzt das Ergebnis?
Was das Ergebnis war an Aschemassen-Konzentrationen, die wir gemessen haben.
Ja, vielleicht mal auch so ein bisschen in der Schlussfolgerung. Also wie gefährlich war es nun wirklich vermutlich für die...
Gut, wie gefährlich das war, das muss ein Tripex-Hersteller selbst sagen. Es ist ja mittlerweile so, dass es jetzt Grenzwerte gibt, nach denen geflogen wird. Und wir sind nur in Bereichen geflogen, die in der Nähe des Grenzwertes oder kleiner als der Grenzwert waren. Und unsere Messungen haben dazu beigetragen, eben Daten für diese Modelle von diesem Volcanic Astrophysical Center bereitzustellen und zu überprüfen, wie gut funktionieren die Modelle, um auch Daten für Flugzeughersteller zu liefern. Wir haben denen diese Größenspektren, die wir gemessen haben, zur Verfügung gestellt. Und die haben dann ein Modell von ihrem Triebwerk und rechnen dann aus, wo würden sich diese Partikel im Triebwerk ablagern. Das ist ein Ergebnis. Dann haben wir da im Mai aus Wien-Island den Massenfluss des Vulkanes gemessen, was auch ein wichtiger Eingabeparameter für die Modelldaten war. Es sind da sehr viele Sachen herausgekommen, die für diesen operationellen Betrieb wichtig sind. Es hat auch einmal dazu geführt, dass das Modell eine zu hohe Konzentration vorhergesagt hatte und aufgrund unserer Messung dann der Luftraum schneller wieder aufgemacht wurde. Das war auch mein Ergebnis.
Welcher Luftraum, der gesamte?
Das war der Luftraum über München am 9. Mai.
Wie lange ging diese ganze Sperrung noch mal? Der Flug dann über Island war dann sozusagen direkt über dem Vulkan. Jetzt hast du gesagt, wir fliegen jetzt nur da, wo die Grenzwerte den Eindruck machen, dass das jetzt nicht so viel ist. Ich meine, da war definitiv zu viel, um da durchzufliegen.
Ja, wir sind da auch nicht durchgeflogen. Wir hatten zwei Fragestellungen in Island. Den Asche-Massenfluss sind wir mit dem Lila drübergeflogen und haben dann entschieden, dass wir da nicht reinfliegen können. Wir haben dann die Windrichtung und Windgeschwindigkeit gemessen von der Asche, die aus dem Vulkan rauskam. Einen Tag später, in 500 km Entfernung vom Vulkan, sind wir in die Aschewolke reingeflogen und können dann natürlich rückrechnen, was da rauskommt, aufgrund der Messungen, die wir dann in größerer Entfernung, in verdünnterer Asche gemacht haben. Und die zweite Fragestellung, die die Isländer auch sehr interessiert hat, wie viel Asche ist über dem Flughafen Reykjavík? Und da waren die Konzentrationen so niedrig, dass man problemlos fliegen konnte.
Weil die Asche zog ja gen Osten, Südosten, wenn ich es richtig erinnere, im Wesentlichen. Und Reykjavík liegt entsprechend auf der anderen Seite.
Genau, und das war eben auch für die Isländer sehr wichtig, dass die Flugzeuge da problemlos fliegen konnten.
Was für eine Reichweite hat man in Bizarre Falcon? Man ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür ausgelegt, ewig durch die Welt durchzuliegen.
Das stimmt, also es hängt natürlich immer davon ab, wir wollen natürlich nicht nur auf Reiseflughöhe fliegen, sondern wir machen dann immer Profile, was dazu führt, also man kann mit der Falcon ungefähr vier bis fünf Stunden fliegen. Und wenn ich dann viele von diesen Vertikalprofilen mache, die dann eine Stunde ungefähr dauern, dann verbraucht man entsprechend viel Sprit, weil man die ganze Zeit hoch und runter muss. Genau, also als wir Richtung Island geflogen sind, sind wir in Schottland zwischengelandet zum Tanken und dann weiter nach Island.
Ja, richtig Abenteuer, ne? Mhm, schon. Hat Spaß gemacht, nehme ich an. Da lacht das Forscherherz Maxi richtig an. Wie lange dauerte dann diese ganze Auseinandersetzung mit dem, also jetzt, wie lange dauerten die jetzt die Messungen so an? Also wie lange wart ihr da so unterwegs damit?
Also wir haben zwischen dem 19. April und dem 18. Mai gemessen, fast einen Monat. Und haben dann am Anfang natürlich nur erst grob ausgewertete Daten präsentiert. Das, normalerweise dauert die Auswertung von so einem Datensatz ein Jahr, eineinhalb Jahre und bis man das überhaupt mal so weit bringt, dass man die ganzen Ergebnisse veröffentlichen kann. Und wir haben jetzt, oder letztes Jahr im Oktober eine riesige Publikation eingereicht, um die 75 Seiten, wo wir die ganzen Ergebnisse zusammenfassen und der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung stellen. Und das ist aber noch nicht das Ende. Man kann mit den Daten noch sehr viel weitere Sachen machen. Zum Beispiel haben wir Asche verschieden Alters vermessen. Und da kann man untersuchen, wie verändert sich die Asche mit zunehmendem Alter. Was auch ein interessantes Ergebnis ist.
Im Sinne von Tagen?
Wir sind in Ascheschichten geflogen, die sieben Stunden alt waren. Und in Ascheschichten, die sechs Tage alt waren. Und da kann man dann Studien machen, was sich auswäscht und so weiter. Oder ob jetzt auf die Partikel so eine Sulfathülle draufgeht.
Ob sich das mit anderen Aerosolen wieder verbunden hat.
Weil der wesentliche Unterschied zwischen der Vulkanasche und dem Sahara-Staub ist nämlich, dass man in der Vulkanasche eben auch noch dieses SO2 drinnen hat und dann auch Schwefelpartikel hat. Und wenn die zum Beispiel zusammenstoßen mit einem Aschepartikel, dann können die zusammen wachsen zu gemischten Partikeln. Und das ist dann auch wieder interessant. Eine Fragestellung wäre da zum Beispiel, welches Messsignal würde ein Bodenlider sehen, wenn diese gemischten Aschesulfat-Teilchen drüberfliegen?
Das heißt, sind diese Daten jetzt der Allgemeinheit verfügbar? Ja, kann man im Internet runterladen. Die gesamten Rohdaten?
Ach so, wir haben in dieser Publikation die Ergebnisse aufbereitet. Es ist aber auch so, wenn uns Kollegen anfragen für ein bestimmtes Projekt oder für eine bestimmte Fragestellung, kriegen die natürlich die Daten. Da kann man auch sehr viele Kollaborationen machen. Wir haben also den Volcanic Ash Advisory Center, mit denen machen wir was mit den englischen Kollegen. Das ist was am Laufen, wo man auch vergleicht, wie gut passt das zusammen, was die gemessen haben, was wir gemessen haben. Dann dem Norwegenischen Institut für Luftforschung haben wir Daten zur Verfügung gestellt. Also wir haben ziemlich viele Leute, dem Verkehrsministerium, dem Deutschen Wetterdienst. Jeder, der die Daten haben wollte, hat sie bekommen.
Und bis das dann alles final ausgewertet ist, da wird noch viel Zeit vergehen. Also so eine Kampagne von einem Monat erzeugt wirklich ein paar Jahre. Daten für zwei, drei Jahre. Na ja, jetzt ist ja die Beeinflussung des Flugverkehrs ein gewisser Hinsicht ein kleines Luxusproblem. Man kann nicht mehr fliegen. Unsere Wirtschaft hängt natürlich zu einem guten Teil davon ab in den Zeiten von Just-in-Time. Da merkt man, wie schnell solche Logistikketten auseinanderbrechen, wenn mal eben kein Flugzeug fliegen kann. Also gar kein Flugzeug fliegen kann. Da muss man dann sicherlich noch mal so eigene Konsequenzen ziehen, ob das immer so gut ist und ob man sich auf so eine permanente Verfügbarkeit des Luftraums so immer verlassen kann und sollte. Aber, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, sind ja die eigentlichen Fragestellungen, gehen ja hier deutlich über solche Probleme hinaus. Es geht um das gesamte Klimamodell des Planeten und hast ja schon angesprochen, zum Beispiel Waldbrände beeinflussen ja auch in einem ähnlichen Maße wie Vulkanausbrüche die Atmosphäre.
Zum Teil sogar noch mehr. Also es kommt immer drauf an, welchen Parameter ich jetzt anschaue. Wenn ich zum Beispiel eben diese Absorption von dem Sonnenlicht in so Waldbrandschichten mir anschaue und das sich Erwärmen von einer atmosphärischen Schicht, dann hat das wahrscheinlich auch Einflüsse aufs Wetter, indem ich quasi die Temperaturverschichtung verändere und damit vielleicht Wolken, die sonst in größeren Höhen wachsen würden, daran hindere, dass sie so groß werden. Da kann man sich alle möglichen Einflüsse noch vorstellen.
Jetzt, Waldbrände werden ja immer gerne so berichtet, weil es gibt ja gute Bilder, brennt schön, so Katastrophen. Wir wissen alle, nicht alles, was katastrophal ist, schafft es auch in unsere Bilderberichtswelt. Waldbrände gehören in gewisser Hinsicht dann trotzdem dazu. Von daher ist es immer sehr schwer, sich ein Bild zu machen, wie groß das Problem jetzt eigentlich ist. So gefühlt würde ich sagen, es brennt eine ganze Menge ab. Was sind denn so die wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse? Wie groß ist denn das Problem von Waldbränden? Gibt es mehr als sonst oder ist das eigentlich alles ganz normal?
Also man sieht, dass in den letzten 20 Jahren die Zahl der Waldbrände stark zugenommen hat. Und vor allem die Zahl der Waldbrände in borealen Gebieten. Boreale Gebiete meinen da zum Beispiel Sibirien, Kanada, Nordamerika. Und diese Schichten, die bei diesen Waldbränden entstehen, ziehen zum Teil auch in die Arktis. Und es kann dann sein, dass sich die schwarzen Partikel auf dem Eis ablagern und dann dazu führen, dass das Eis vielleicht schneller abschmilzt als es ohne die Rußpartikel darauf passieren würde. Das sind zum Beispiel Sachen, die man beobachtet.
Seit 20 Jahren?
In den letzten 20 Jahren. Ja, das hat damit zu tun, dass sich das Klima verändert und dass man zum Teil größere Trockenzeiten hat und dass vor allem in diesen nördlichen Regionen die Temperatur einfach sehr viel stärker angestiegen ist. Im globalen Mittel ist die Temperatur in den letzten 120 Jahren ungefähr um 0,75 Grad angestiegen. Aber in den nördlichen Regionen hat man einen sehr höheren Temperaturanstieg. Das führt dazu, dass man zum Teil das wärmer ist, dass man mehr Trockenheiten hat, dass dann ein Blitzschlag viel schneller mal einen Wald anzünden kann.
Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit von Waldbränden wird erhöht und es zeigt sich auch ganz konkret an der Zählung von Waldbränden. Ich meine, es ist vielleicht etwas schwierig zu quantifizieren. Was ist jetzt ein Waldbrand?
Von der Fläche her. Da gibt es auch unterschiedliche Definitionen. Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf hab, dann werden pro Jahr in den nördlichen Regionen ungefähr 5 bis 10 Millionen Hektar Fläche verbrannt durch solche Waldbrände.
Pro Jahr 5 bis 10 Millionen Hektar. Das sind so kleinere Staaten. Jedes Jahr verbrennt ein kleinerer Staat.
Gut, es wachsen natürlich dann auch wieder Bäume nach.
Aber wie groß wird das Problem angesehen?
Das ist eine aktuelle Fragestellung, an der wir gerade forschen, weil wir es noch nicht genau wissen.
Zunächst einmal nur eine Beobachtung.
Es brennt mehr. Ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt, dass Ruß im Verdacht steht, nach CO2 am zweitstärksten zur Klimaerwärmung beizutragen. Da sind die Waldbrände natürlich auch Kandidaten, die da einen Beitrag liefern.
Wie lange wird denn an diesem Bereich schon geforscht? Wie lange sind Aerosole-Partikel jetzt auch wirklich ein Teil? War das schon immer so? Oder ist das eine Sache, die eigentlich erst mit modernen Messgeräten...
Also es gibt natürlich auch in den 60er, 70er Jahren gab es schon Bodenmessungen in Wüstengebieten, aber so richtig diese Flugzeugmessungen, die sind erst in der Zeit populär geworden. Und es ist auch so, mit zunehmender Zeit hat sich natürlich die Messtechnik verbessert, man hat bessere Messverfahren, man kann genauer messen. Vor allem für den Ruß sind in den letzten vier, fünf Jahren sehr viele neue Messmethoden entstanden, mit denen man das besser vermessen kann, wie viel Ruß überhaupt da ist. Und das ist ein ganz aktuelles Thema, brandaktuell sozusagen.
Vorhin hast du noch als Art von Aerosolen auch Seesalz genannt. Wovon reden wir denn? Reden wir denn jetzt auch von dem Verdampfen von Salz auf dem Meer?
In erster Linie entsteht das Seesalz. Man hat ja den Wind, der über das Meer drüber bläst und dann entstehen diese Luftbläschen und dadurch wird das Salz in die Luft emittiert. Das ist eigentlich die größte natürliche Aerosolquelle, ist das Meer mit dem Seesalz.
Und was weiß man über das Salz? Weiß welche Auswirkungen das hat? Ist es jetzt nicht so ein Absorber wie?
Mit dem Salz, das ist natürlich zum Teil nur in Schichten, die ein paar hundert Meter über dem Wasser sich befinden und wird dann auch relativ schnell wieder ausgewaschen. Also ich habe mich bisher nicht so sehr mit Salz beschäftigt.
Aber was ja auf den Meeren auch stattfindet, ist ja der Schiffsverkehr. Also es fahren ja wirklich sehr viele Schiffe über unsere Meere und man möchte jetzt immer so meinen, naja, sind ja nur so ein paar Schiffe. Aber tatsächlich tragen Schiffe ganz erheblich zu den Gesamtemissionen, die so aus dem Verbrennen von Öl vortreten, bei. Ist das auch Teil der Forschung?
Es gibt eine Kollegin, die Frau Eiring, bei uns am Institut, die hat eine Nachwuchsforschungsgruppe, die sich genau mit diesen Schiffsemissionen beschäftigt hat. Und die haben sehr viel herausgefunden in den letzten fünf, sechs Jahren über diese Schiffsemissionen, dass die ihm einen sehr großen Beitrag zu den Partikel-Emissionen bieten und die haben auch Simulationen gemacht. Also was passiert, wenn der Schiffsverkehr sich weiter zunimmt und wie wirkt sich das auf die Wolken aus? Also gab es hier viel Forschung dazu.
Also das ist auch eine Kernaufgabe.
Das ist auch eine Kernaufgabe, die Verkehrseffekte abzuschätzen.
Der Wald war ja auch schon immer so ein Thema. Ich erinnere mich noch, in den 80er Jahren gab es ja viel Aufhebens um das Waldsterben. Auch das war ja im Prinzip ein atmosphärischer Effekt. Man spricht vom sauren Regen.
Genau.
Was ist da passiert und wie hat sich denn das so entwickelt über die letzten 20, 30 Jahre? Existiert dieses Problem noch in demselben Maße?
Also ich würde sagen, es existiert nicht mehr in demselben Maße und das ist eigentlich auch so eine Erfolgsstory, würde ich mal sagen, wie Forschung dazu beitragen kann, dass man die Welt besser schützt. Das Problem war ja dieser saure Regen, dass man sehr viele Schwefeldioxid-Emissionen hatte aus Industrieabgasen, die dann dazu geführt haben, dass der Wald zerstört worden ist. Man hat dann Forschungen gemacht und verstanden, was das Problem ist und hat dann einfach angefangen, Filter einzubauen in die ganzen Industrieanlagen, die das SO2 herausfiltern. Und dadurch hat man das Problem in den Griff bekommen.
Das heißt einfach, die klare Erkenntnis der Wissenschaft, es gibt einfach ein Problem mit den konkreten Emissionen der Industrie, lass doch mal was machen, hat dann eben über den entsprechenden politischen Druck, der dann über Jahre aufgebaut wurde, auch tatsächlich eine Reversion dieses Problems geführt.
Genau, oder zumindest in Eingrenzen, ja.
Sodass es jetzt in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht mehr, also nicht mehr so schlimm ist, aber es gibt nach wie vor diese Emissionen.
Ja, sehr viel weniger.
Sehr viel weniger. Okay, für mich ein bisschen schwierig, das zu quantifizieren.
Was zum Beispiel auch ein recht interessanter Effekt war, nach dem Fall des eisernen Vorhangs, ist ja auch die Industrie im Osten zusammengebrochen und man hat neue Anlagen aufgebaut. Und da sieht man einen sehr klaren Effekt, dass eben diese SO2-Emissionen abgenommen haben und dadurch sich auch die Farbe der Wolken verändert hat. Also das ist zum Beispiel auch ein Aerosol. Aerosole wirken ja zweifach auf das Klima. Zum einen durch Streuung und Absorption von dem Sonnenlicht. Und der zweite Effekt, dass sie eben als Wolkenkondensationskeim wirken können. Und sie können dadurch in ihrer Art das Wolkenkondensationskeim auch Wolken verändern. Wenn ich jetzt sehr viele Aerosolpartikel in der Atmosphäre habe, dann führt das dazu, dass ich in einer Wolke sehr viele kleine Wolkentröpfchen bekomme. Und der Effekt ist dann, dass die Wolke weißer ausschaut, mir Licht in den Weltraum zurückreflektiert und am Boden eine Kühlung verursacht. Und die Lebenszeit der Wolken kann sich dadurch auch verändern, wenn ich natürlich mehr kleine Tröpfchen in der Wolke habe, wird die Wolke nicht so schnell regnen, als wenn ich viele große Tröpfchen in der Wolke habe. Das liegt daran, in der Wolke habe ich einen Aufwind. Und dieser Aufwind hebt das Tröpfchen in der Wolke, das schwebt quasi. Und wenn es dann irgendwann zu groß wird, dass es zu schwer ist, dann fällt es aus der Wolke raus und es regnet. Wenn ich jetzt sehr viele kleine Tröpfchen drin habe, kann ich die sehr viel länger in der Wolke halten, die Wolke kann länger leben.
Das heißt, dadurch, dass es weniger Partikel gab, nachdem der Osten seine emissionsreiche Industrie heruntergefahren hat, waren die Wolken nicht mehr so weiß?
Ja, genau. Und ein absurder Effekt ist eigentlich auch, dass der Aerosoleffekt wirkt im Ganzen kühlend auf die Effekte von allen Aerosolpartikeln. Als man natürlich dann angefangen hat, diese Schwefelfilter einzubauen, hat man natürlich das stark streuende Schwefelerosol aus der Atmosphäre entfernt. Und dieser Schwefeleffekt hat quasi dazu geführt, dass der Temperaturanstieg, der durch das anthropogene CO2 verursacht wird, maskiert wurde. Also die Temperatur ist nicht ganz so schnell angestiegen, als man es erwartet hätte, weil man eben den gegenläufigen Effekt hat. Jetzt haben wir die Aerosolpartikel entfernt, hat den Wald geschützt, aber dafür steigt die Temperatur mehr an. Also es gibt nichts umsonst auf der Erde. Man kann sich überlegen, welchen Effekt man lieber hat.
Gleich sich alles aus. Aber ich meine, das ist ja auch die große Debatte, der Klimawandel. Man merkt immer wieder viele kleine, das haben jetzt viele Beispiele ja gezeigt. Man hat jetzt hier einen Vulkanausbruch und auf einmal ist dann für ein paar Jahre die Temperaturentwicklung ganz anders, als man sie vorhergesagt hat, eben weil einfach da niemand natürlich diesen Vulkanausbruch so hätte vorher sagen können. Man kann wahrscheinlich auf Basis von Wahrscheinlichkeit sagen, naja, wir haben jetzt so und so viele Vulkanausbrüche gehabt, aber wenn dann mal wieder was ganz Fettes kommt, dann sind ja die Wirkungen extrem. Und genauso wirken sich eben jetzt zahlreiche Maßnahmen, wie zum Beispiel die Filternachrüstung etc. auch immer irgendwie aus und die Wechselwirkungen sind ja sehr, sehr weitgehend. Der Klimawandel als solcher befindet sich ja extrem in der öffentlichen Diskussion. Und manchmal hat man das Gefühl, die Gesellschaft spaltet sich in die Leute, die das halt so sehen. Und es gibt Leute, die das einfach nicht so sehen können oder wollen. Wie sieht denn das in der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft aus? Also wie wird das Thema dort behandelt?
Also es gibt keine einzige Publikation, die sagen würde, den vom Menschen verursachten Klimawandel gibt es nicht. Keine einzige. Also mir ist keine bekannt. Und es ist auch so, man kann ja messen, dass der CO2-Gehalt ansteigt. Sehr stark. Und man weiß aus Eisbohrkern-Messungen, dass das CO2 sehr stark mit der Temperatur gekoppelt ist. Also man kann Eisbohrkernen immer bohren, ins Eis runter und hat dann in dem gefrorenen Eis Luft eingeschlossen, die jetzt 100.000 oder 400.000 Jahre alt ist. Und dann kann man durch ein sehr arbeitsintensives Verfahren eben rekonstruieren, wie hoch war der CO2-Gehalt zu einer bestimmten Zeit und wie hoch war die Temperatur zu einer bestimmten Zeit. Und da sieht man, dass wenn CO2-Gehalt hoch war, war die Temperatur hoch. Wenn CO2-Gehalt nieder war, war die Temperatur niedrig. Und da gibt es...
Also einen klaren Zusammenhang zwischen CO2 und Temperatur.
Genau. Und man kann ja messen, dass der CO2-Gehalt sehr stark steigt.
Und wie stark steigt der?
Die Rate weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Man weiß, dass in den letzten 400.000 Jahren hat der CO2-Gehalt zwischen 0,02 und 0,028% an der Atmosphäre betragen. Und im Moment sind wir bei 0,038%, also deutlich höher als in den letzten 400.000 Jahren.
D.h. auch, was man ja häufig hört, ist so, naja, es kommt ja immer mal wieder eine Eiszeit und das mit den Temperaturen geht ja auch auf der Erde immer wieder hoch und runter.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt schon. Eiszeit kommt sicher auch in 10.000 Jahren oder so wieder. Aber unser Problem sind die nächsten 100 Jahre.
D.h. es passt sozusagen nicht zur Entwicklung. Also selbst wenn man jetzt die natürlichen Schwankungen, die einfach stattfinden, mit einrechnet, ist das so, wie es sich eigentlich verhalten müsste. Wenn man das Ganze mit den Messungen z.B. in den Eisbock-Kernen vergleicht, wahrscheinlich nicht die einzigen Messungen, die da herangezogen werden, dann passt das nicht zusammen. D.h. man kann klar sagen, irgendetwas hat der Mensch getan, um diese Erwärmung zu verursachen. Und es ist vermutlich das CO2, aber es ist auch nicht nur das CO2.
Nee, es ist das CO2, es ist das Methan. Das sind die wichtigsten Faktoren, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Es sind auch noch andere Spuren, als die Ozone.
Wenn sich die wissenschaftliche Gemeinde so einig ist, fühlt sie sich dann eigentlich ausreichend verstanden von der Öffentlichkeit in der Debatte?
Man hat eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit, es immer und immer wieder zu erklären. Und mit jedem Menschen, dem ich es erkläre, überzeug ich einen mehr.
Und ist das schwierig?
Ich denke, in der direkten Diskussion, wenn man einfach mal die Fakten auf den Tisch legt, sagt der Zusammenhang in der Vergangenheit, Temperatur, CO2 ist da. Es gibt natürlich auch diese natürlichen Variabilitäten. Man kann jetzt zum Beispiel das Experiment machen, ich nehme ein Modell und versuche, die Temperaturentwicklung zu simulieren. Dann weiß ich, welche natürlichen Effekte es gibt. Es kann zum Beispiel sein, dass die Sonne mal stärker, mal weniger stark Energie liefert. Es kann sein, dass sich die Bahnparameter von der Erde ein bisschen ändern und dadurch mehr oder weniger Energie von der Sonne auf die Erde kommt. Diese Effekte, die natürlichen, weiß ich alle. Dann kann ich mal hergehen und ausrechnen, wie wird sich die Temperatur entwickeln, wenn ich nur diese natürlichen Antriebe nehme. Dann kann ich das mit der Messung vergleichen. Wenn ich nur die natürlichen Faktoren nehme, bin ich nicht in der Lage, die gemessene Temperaturentwicklung zu reproduzieren. Die gemessene Temperaturentwicklung geht nach oben. Das mit den natürlichen Faktoren schwankt einfach so. Wenn ich jetzt aber den anthropogenen Effekt, also das anthropogen emittierte CO2, das man sehr gut messen kann, mit dazu nehme, dann sehe ich, dass ich sehr gut in der Lage bin, die gemessene Temperaturkurve zu reproduzieren. Das war schon ein sehr starkes Indizes, dass da der Mensch mit dran beteiligt ist.
Dass da ein Unbelieberer zusammen steckt. Und es gibt auch keine unvorhergesehenen Sonderfälle in unserem Universum, die jetzt in irgendeiner Form mit mit reinspielen können? So Sonnenstrahlungsänderungen?
Auf lange Sicht ändert sich die Sonnenstrahlung natürlich schon. Also die Sonne wird heißer und wird noch ungemütlicher werden, aber das dauert noch so lange, dass das nach der nächsten Eiszeit sein wird.
Aber auch solche Faktoren sind berücksichtigt in diesem Modell?
Ja, doch. Das sind ja diese natürlichen Antriebe, die man berücksichtigt.
Tja, haben wir denn irgendeinen wichtigen Punkt der Arbeit rund um die Atmosphäre und der Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt noch übersehen in unserem Überblick? Ja, ich habe hier auch jetzt nichts mehr auf meiner kleinen Notizliste von Dingen, über die man schon immer mal hätte sprechen wollen. Wäre ja gerne dabei gewesen, wenn es so über den Vulkan ging.
Das war sehr beeindruckend.
War bestimmt ein schicker Blick, oder?
Also man sitzt im Flugzeug und schaut auf diesen Vulkan, der da große Aschevolk oder Teile ausspuckt. Das sind dann immer wie so Explosionen. Das hat was Meistertisches. Es sind halt diese Naturgewalten. Das ist schön, so lange man weit genug weg ist.
Ich fand die Bilder aus Island auch so beeindruckend, weil in diesen Wolken auch immer noch solche Blitze abliefen.
Das haben wir jetzt nicht gesehen. In Island ist ja auch eine richtige Wolke, die dann rauszieht und immer breiter wird, je weiter sie wegkommt vom Vulkan. Das ist auch dieser Verdünnungseffekt. Über Deutschland ist dann keine Wolke mehr. Da sind es eher dünne Schichten. Das war vielleicht der Grund, warum manche Leute Anfang April in den Himmel geschaut haben und so einen leicht hellblauen Himmel gesehen haben. Wo ist die Wolke? Es ist ja eigentlich blauer Himmel. Man hat es gesehen, wenn man genau hingeschaut hat, weil der Himmel eben nicht dunkelblau war wie normal, sondern nur dieses Hellblaue. Und dieses Hellblaue war dadurch verursacht, dass diese Aschepartikel eben das Licht gestreut haben.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen der Blick des Meteorologen, dass man das Weiß der Wolken unterscheidet.
Ja, das war ja nicht das Weiß der Wolken, sondern das war das Hellblau, der solch richtig da oben war.
Wie viele Namen für Wolkenfarben hat der Meteorologe so üblicherweise am Start? So ein bisschen wie mit den Eskimos und dem Schnee, den ja auch immer nachgesagt wird, dass jetzt so viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten haben, Schneefarben zu unterscheiden. Ich glaube, bei den Meteorologen ist es ähnlich. Ja, Benadette, vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier zur Atmosphäre. Auf jeden Fall interessanter Einblick, auch insbesondere in diese Sondersituation, der Analyse der Vulkanasche mit dem Vulkan mit dem unansprechlichen Namen. Ich werde mir jetzt gar keine Mühe geben, es hier richtig oder falsch zu machen. Ja, danke und wie auch immer, danke fürs Zuhören bei dieser Episode, die nicht geletzt geblieben sein wird, hier bei Raumzeit. Es geht natürlich weiter alle zwei Wochen frisch auf den Tisch. Interessante Gespräche mit Wissenschaftlern und Organisatoren aus der Raumfahrt und aus den verwandten Forschungsgebieten, so wie wir das heute gehabt haben. Die Zusammenhänge sind ja da sehr vielfältig und ich denke, das hat das Thema heute auch wieder gezeigt.